Ay no es Presidente,
él es Jorge Álvarez maines.
Soy maines y el México nuevo va en serio.
El candidato presidencial de movimiento ciudadano.
Es originario de Zacatecas y tiene 38 años de edad.
Paso por la política mexicana
lo ha llevado a transitar por las filas del PRD,
nueva alianza,
el PRI y por último movimiento ciudadano.
Por supuesto que es un honor tener un pensado
del que uno se siente orgulloso.
Estudió relaciones
internacionales en el instituto tecnológico
y de estudios superiores de occidente
y es maestro en administración pública
por el Tec de Monterrey.
Movimiento ciudadano mandó al PRIAN al tercer lugar.
También cuenta con estudios de maestría en derecho
constitucional
y derechos humanos
por el centro de estudios jurídicos Carbonell
en 2 003
y inició su trayectoria política en el PRD y en 2 004
fue regidor del ayuntamiento
del municipio de Zacatecas.
En 2 010 fue postulado por nueva alianza
como diputado del Congreso del estado de Zacatecas.
Va a estar en la boleta,
la única opción decente.
Ese mismo año se incorporó a la bancada del PRI.
En 2 013 se unió a movimiento ciudadano
ocupando los puestos de secretario de organización
y acción política Nacional de ese partido.
Además se desempeñó como diputado
plurinominal Federal de 2 015 a 2 018,
abanderado por el instituto naranja
y regresó a San Lázaro en 2 021.
Yo no soy el que era un lambiscón
empleado del secretario de gobernación Osorio Chong,
donde coordinó la bancada de movimiento ciudadano.
Quienes están en el poder piensan Que serán eternos
lo piensan quienes están hoy y lo pensaron quienes
estuvieron ayer.
Jorge Álvarez maines,
inicialmente se había desempeñado
como coordinador de la precampaña de Samuel García,
sin embargo, el gobernador de Nuevo León
decidió retirarse de la contienda.
El precandidato y próximo
Presidente de la República de México,
después de un proceso interno,
movimiento ciudadano
determinó que su abanderado
para la carrera presidencial
sería Jorge Álvarez maines.
Quien busca acabar con la llamada vieja política.
Podrá remontar,
le vamos a ganar a la vieja política, porque México
merece un mejor futuro y porque lo nuevo
apenas comienza.
Muchas gracias